قبل أربعة أشهر فقط ، كانت هذه بلدة مزدحمة يسكنها
11000 شخص ،
ثم جاءت الفيضانات على
نطاق توراتي
وتركتها مغمورة تحت الماء
وانقطعت إلى حد كبير
عند وصولنا إلى دينغ دينغ ، وهناك القليل
من علامات الحياة ،
فقط بعض المتعلقات مخبأة في
رؤوس الأشجار
هي الحماية الوحيدة  من المياه
التي غمرت معظم جنوب السودان ،
فغمرت هذه المدينة بأكملها
منذ آب / أغسطس وما زالت المياه تتزايد
أكثر فأكثر على الرغم من
انتهاء موسم الأمطار الآن.
أين منازلك
دمرت
منازلك ، لقد نجوا من سنوات الحرب الأهلية الشرسة
هنا ،
لكن هذه الفيضانات قد تشكل أكبر
تهديد ، ومع
ذلك يخبروننا أن محاصيلهم قد
دمرت تمامًا ،
فماذا تعيش الآن
ما الذي تعيش فيه
على الزنابق
نعم الزنابق ، زنابق الماء
هم أناس يمرضون من المياه القذرة ،
كثير من الناس يعانون من أمراض تنقلها المياه
ماسرا كاسارا
، تمت تغطية جميع الآبار لذلك  علينا أن
نشرب هذه المياه في
حين أن جنوب السودان ليس غريباً عن
الفيضانات الموسمية. لم تتأثر دولة الوحدة
بهذا الشكل منذ أوائل الستينيات من القرن الماضي ،
يقول العلماء إن الفيضانات أصبحت
أكثر حدة ولا يمكن التنبؤ بها في
السنوات الأخيرة ، ويرجع ذلك جزئيًا إلى
الاحتباس الحراري
جيمس
مرحبًا  جيمس
جيمس لوين هو واحد من مئات
الآلاف الذين تم تهجيرهم ،
وهو يوافق على أن يطلعنا على ما تبقى من
منزل عائلته ،
يا إلهي ،
هذه دراجتك النارية ،
نعم ،
لم يتبق شيء
باستثناء رسومات أطفاله
على الجدران
منذ اندلاع النزاع.
أخذ قسطًا من الراحة ، أخبرنا أننا كنا
نركض باستمرار ،
ولم يخف أطفالنا من
المخاطر
الآن ، وهو مجبر على الفرار مرة
أخرى ، فالرحلة إلى الوعد بالأرض الجافة
طويلة
وشاقة ، حيث يسافر المحظوظون بالقوارب
معظمهم يسبحون  أو نتحرك ببطء ولكن
بشكل هادف عبر المياه الموحلة ،
تدفع بعض العوامات المؤقتة المكدسة عالياً
مع أفراد الأسرة والممتلكات
التي نصادفها مجموعة من النساء
لقد علقت في
الوحل ، ذهب رجال العائلة
لمحاولة إنقاذ ماشيتهم ،
يخبرنا ناريكا أنهم غادروا
منزلهم المدمر منذ أربعة أيام ، هل
كنت تدفع هذه الطوافة لمدة أربعة أيام
[موسيقى]
نعم أخبرونا
طوال الطريق أنهم  يقولون إن طعامهم نفد ،
كم يبلغ عمر طفلك؟
أه من خمسة إلى ستة أشهر من خمسة إلى ستة أشهر
، هل أنت قلق بشأن أطفالك
[موسيقى]
نعم ، أنا قلقة كما تقول
، ولهذا السبب نستمر في التحرك
، لا يزال أمامهم عدة أميال لدفعها
قبل ذلك  الوصول إلى هذا الشريط الضيق من
الأرض الجافة
وفقًا لليونيسيف ، استقر حوالي 6000
شخص هنا
يعتمدون بشكل كامل على المساعدة للبقاء على قيد الحياة
وليس لديهم مرحاض وليس لديهم
ما يكفي من الطعام ليأكلوه لذلك
ليس لديهم حمامات لا يرتدونها  ليس لدي
أي طعام وهناك المزيد من الأشخاص
الذين يصلون كل يوم يستمر الناس في
القيام بهذا المكان ويستمرون في
القدوم ، من الواضح أنك تفعل كل
ما في وسعك ولكن هل هذا يكفي
وهذا ليس كافيًا وهذا هو
سبب دعوتنا إلى عدم  أو المجتمعات
للتأكد من أنك تعرف أن
الأطفال يذهبون إلى المدرسة ، يحصل الأطفال على الرعاية الصحية ، وأنهم
يتلقون خدمات المغذيات ، وعلينا التأكد من
أنك تعلم أننا نمنعهم من الموت ،
تستمر المياه الراكدة في الارتفاع ، وكذلك
الأمراض مثل الإسهال والتهاب الكبد الوبائي
وسوء التغذية لدى الأطفال هي الآن  في
أعلى مستوى لها منذ عام 2013.
أولئك الذين وصلوا
إلى عاصمة الولاية وجدوا ملاذًا صغيرًا
تم تحويل بعض الطرق الرئيسية
إلى ممرات مائية واستبدلت السيارات بالزوارق على
بعد ميل واحد فقط من البقايا الشبحية
لما كان ذات يوم تجاريًا
كان هذا هو منطقة التسوق المركزية
في المدينة حيث يمكنك أن ترى
مدمرًا تمامًا
وفقًا للسلطات 90 في المائة من
حالة الوحدة قد تأثرت بهذه
الفيضانات
هنا ، فإن تأثيرات تغير المناخ
ليست مشكلة افتراضية في
المستقبل
بل هي مشكلة حقيقية  كارثة في
الوقت الحاضر
نحن نكافح لمنع وصول هذه المياه
إلى هنا
الوزير لام تانغوار يقر بأن
السلطات المحلية لم تكن مستعدة على الإطلاق.
ونحن الآن غير قادرين على التعامل مع
حجم الأزمة ،
ليس لدينا ما يكفي للبقاء على
قيد الحياة إلى
أي مدى يمكنك التعامل مع
الموقف كما هو واقعي يمكنني
أن أخبرك بصراحة
أننا لا نعرف ولكننا فقط  قلقون
بشأن المطر القادم لأنه قيل لنا
أن الماء خلفي لن يذهب الآن
ولن يقاوموا الآن أو يجف ،
سيستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت لأن المياه العميقة
ليس لديهم وقت طويل ومن المتوقع هطول الأمطار القادمة
في مايو و
إذا لم تنحسر المياه الحالية ، فإن الخوف هو أن
هذه المنطقة سيتم محوها من الخريطة
التي يتم بناؤها لمحاولة
كبح المياه الزاحفة ،
لكن حفنة من الحفارين لا تتناسب
مع
ثغرات الفيضانات الواسعة مما يترك الكثيرين مع  لا يوجد
خيار سوى أخذ الأمور
بأيديهم على عجل ، وارتجال
حماية منازلهم المهددة بالانقراض
حيث تستمر المياه في الارتفاع بهدوء